ثمانية مليارات دولار كان
الحجم التقديري لصناعة تبييض البشرة
في عام 2020. هذا سوق
ضخم ينمو بسرعة في شعبيته
خاصة بين النساء اللواتي يمثلن
ما يقرب من 80 في المائة من المبيعات في جميع أنحاء العالم
، ويتغذى بالكامل تقريبًا من الرغبة في
الحصول على لون أفتح  الجلد ولكن هذه هي
التكلفة المحتملة على صحتك
، فقد وجد أن المنتجات التي
تساعد الأشخاص على تفتيح بشرتهم غالبًا ما
تحتوي على مستويات عالية من الزئبق والعديد
من مصنعي الكريمات يحذفون
الزئبق في ملصقاتهم أو قوائم المكونات الخاصة بهم.
الصحة ، لذلك دعونا نتحدث
عن السبب في أن الشكل الأكثر شيوعًا
للزئبق في كريمات تبييض البشرة هو
أملاح الزئبق التي لا يمكنك رؤيتها حقًا
والتي تختلف عن الزئبق السائل
الذي قد تربطه بمقاييس الحرارة
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالمخاطر الصحية ، فإن
العامل الرئيسي هو كيف  الكثير من الزئبق في
المنتج ، جزء واحد في المليون هو
المستوى المسموح به من الزئبق في مستحضرات التجميل
والذي تحدده الميناء  اتفاقية mata بشأن
الزئبق التي تسمح باستثناءات
لمستحضرات تجميل معينة لمنطقة العين ولكن العديد من
كريمات تبييض البشرة تتجاوز هذا
المستوى
بشكل كبير وقد وجد أن بعضها يحتوي على أكثر من 10000 جزء في
المليون من الزئبق والبعض الآخر
يصل إلى 50000 جزء في المليون أو أكثر
وتأثير ذلك  غالبًا
ما تتراوح المكونات غير المرئية من إتلاف
بشرتك إلى تأثيرات صحية أكثر خطورة ،
وإليك نظرة عامة على ما يمكن أن تفعله
لك عند وضع الكريمات يتم
امتصاص الزئبق في الجلد حيث
يمنع إنتاج الميلانين
وهو الصباغ الذي يعطي لونًا
لبشرتك  ولكن هذا ليس كل ما يمكن للزئبق
أن ينتقل إلى مجرى الدم
ويصل إلى الدماغ حيث يمكن أن يسبب
مشاكل عصبية بما في
ذلك الاكتئاب والقلق.
حساسة بشكل خاص لسمية الزئبق
يمكن أن يؤدي التعرض للزئبق أثناء الحمل
الضرر العصبي الذي يصيب الأطفال
مما يؤدي إلى مشاكل في النمو في مرحلة الطفولة المبكرة ،
هل تعلم أنه يمكن أيضًا أن
ينتقل من الأم إلى طفلها من خلال
الرضاعة الطبيعية ، كما يمكن أن يكون الأطفال
معرضين لخطر التعرض إذا كان لديهم
ملامسة منتظمة للجلد مع شخص
يستخدم كريمات تحتوي على الزئبق مثل  وكذلك من
خلال الطعام الذي أعده
شخص يستخدم هذه المنتجات ومن
خلال الملابس والفراش حيث
وجد أن الزئبق يتراكم في
الغسالات عندما تكون الملابس التي يرتديها المستخدمون عبارة عن
كريمات مغسولة يمكن أن تؤدي أيضًا إلى
تواجد بخار الزئبق في
هواء المنازل  يمكن أن يتسبب استنشاق الزئبق في
أضرار جسيمة للجسم حيث سيتم
امتصاصه عن طريق الرئتين ثم الانتقال إلى
أعضاء أخرى ، وهذا يعني أن كل شخص
يعيش في منزل تستخدم فيه كريمات تبييض البشرة
المحتوية على الزئبق قد
يكون معرضًا لخطر التعرض للزئبق ،
وهذا قد يبدو مزعجًا  لكن العديد من
تحذيرات الصحة العامة صنفت
مجموعة واسعة من الكريمات التي وجدت أنها تحتوي على
مستويات عالية من الزئبق  يتم تحديثها
بانتظام
[موسيقى]